auf einmal dachte ich mich trifft der
schlag weil der typ neben mir in mich
rein gezogen ist also wieder der fu
parallel neben mir sowie foren so beide
ich rechts eher links und auf einmal
zack kriege ich einen schlag und der
väter in meine linke seite rein
so sei es casey states wieder einmal für
euch mit einer neuen video und wir
spielen heute charlie chaplin oder call
of plenty to und trotz meines etwas
ungewöhnlichen aufzugs möchte ich euch
heute eine sehr sehr sehr ernste
geschichte erzählen das war es nämlich
richtig richtig krass um ganz vorne
anzufangen
ich hab ja ob twitter gesagt dass ich
meine mutter in der reha besuchen werde
diesen der reha in der nähe von münchen
eine stunde entfernt von münchen und ich
bin wiederum drei stunden vom auto
entfernt in dem ort wo sie eben in der
area ist so und ich habe sie am 5 6
besucht genau am 5 6 vorgestern wenn ihr
das video es heute sehr tolles ipv6 an
der tag an dem ich das video aufnehmen
und am 05 06 habe ich sie besucht sowie
mittags hingefahren
das war schon richtig krass die sonne
hat übels gebrannte auf der autobahn
ich habe mich glaube ich auf den drei
stunden autofahrt dreimal eingecremt mit
sonnencreme war ja wohl richtig schüssel
oder so einwerben auto auto wird recht
autobrand sagen
je älter wer von euch kennt noch die
situation dass man einfach ein autobrand
hat vor lauter sonne also das auto fing
an zu brennen
vielleicht seine kommentare kennen sich
einige von euch was ich eigentlich sagen
wollte ist genau ich fand ihn sehr unter
gesagt es war der chiemsee bleibt dann
da und war abends wieder zurück weil ich
wie gesagt hab ja wir haben noch
diskutiert ob ich noch eine nacht
bleiben sollte da in der city
aber dann haben wir gesagt okay ich
fahre lieber nochmal die verlierer da
hin zurück wo ich jetzt wohne das sind
gesagt drei stunden von da und da bin
ich zurück gefahren abend sie habe mich
um 11 auf den weg gemacht oder so weil
ich nachts sehr sehr gerne auto fahre
und deswegen das eigentlich kein ding
ist für mich also drei stunden macht ist
nichts für mich offen aber es lief
anders der grund bei euch das heute
erzähle ist liegt nämlich folgendermaßen
ich fahre richtung münchen also ich bin
über münchen gefahren herunter
ich bin richtung münchen gefahren und
auf einmal es war glaube ich nach fünf
oder zehn minuten vor münchen denke ich
ich werde nicht mehr weiße war einfach
so ein typ neben mir und herzlich
gedacht ja ganz ehrlich autobahn um die
uhrzeit ist schon langweilig wir machen
das mal anders
wer hat sich denn gedacht auf der
autobahn immer so einfach geradeaus zu
fahren nicht mit den anderen leuten was
zu machen ist einfach langweilig und hat
sich einfach gedacht wir spielen jetzt
mal autoscooter und es ist kein witz ich
bin 120 gefahren und auf einmal dachte
ich mich trifft der schlag weil der typ
neben mir in mich rein gezogen ist also
wieder der fu parallel neben mir sowie
foren so beide ich rechts eher links und
auf einmal zack kriege ich einen schlag
und der fall in meine linke seite rein
also zieht rüber und ultra kaspar 120
sachen müsst euch mal geben und ich hab
ich gedacht als ich hab' ich hab gar
nicht gedacht in dem moment aber ich ja
es war einfach richtig schick aber das
war noch längst nicht alles also wir
sind dann nach münchen rhein gefahren
haben dann da die daten ausgetauscht man
das so macht das ja gar kein gewissen
tricky hier macht es denn überhaupt
richtig die daten ausgetauscht haben
schon richtig zu machen
und dann schien ist so dass ich wohl
weiter fahren könnte mir gedacht dass
ich weiter fahren könnte man ein auto
nicht so sehr beschädigt ist also unsere
beiden autos hatten ordentliche
lackschäden aus und so weiter meine ein
kotflügel verbeult aber werden gedacht
wir könnten weiter fahren also dass ich
weiter fahren könnte er auch so dann
sind wir weiter gefahren
es war wohlgemerkt schon nachts um zwei
sind wir weiter gefahren und ich weiß
gar nicht wie ich jetzt hier dran kommen
soll
also wissen weitergefahren und dann fein
raus aus münchen
und ja dann fahre ich schon wieder raus
aus münchen und dann auf einmal platzt
mir der linke vorderreifen wie fucking
sie und ich hatte zu dem zeitpunkt kein
handy dabei bzw ich hatte ein handy
dabei aber meine sim karte war gesperrt
weil ich den pin
damals hatte noch mal die idee an mich
also konnte ich auch keinen kann ich
konnte kein abschlepper rufen kann die
polizei nicht rufen und es war nachts um
halb drei und ich war auf einer autobahn
am arsch der welt und auf der autobahn
liegengeblieben ist nicht so chillig
leute weil die leute die es wirklich
ultraschnell wie die autos da
vorbeifahren wenn ihr am rand steht das
ist wirklich schon ist schon fast
beängstigend wie schnell die autos
fahren
und ja dann steht er so am rand und ich
habe erhalte ich wusste erst nicht was
ich machen soll hab ich gesagt okay ich
will erst mal noch ein paar gedanken
sitzt im auto gut dann ausgestiegen
vorschriftsgemäß die unfallstelle
gesichert und ein warndreieck mir selbst
die warnweste angezogen davor natürlich
es war aber eigentlich komplett richtig
was ich gemacht habe und dann hab ich
mir diesen diesen kleinen pfeiler
angeschaut wisst ja neben der autobahn
stehen immer so dieses schwarz-weißen
pfeiler die die in abständen von 50 mal
50 mal 50 metern die distanz markieren
und dann ist mir eingefallen warte mal
da war doch was
und da habe ich mich an meine ich glaube
es war meine erste hilfe ein erste hilfe
kurs war das damals für den
autoführerschein an dem ich mich dann
erinnert ab und da habe ich nämlich
gelernt dass
auf diesen schwarz weißen säulen ein
pfeil drauf ist er zur nächsten
notrufsäule leitet und dann hab ich
drauf geschaut tatsächlich war auch ein
fall drauf und dann bin ich entsprechend
da dann die straße runter gelaufen also
am rand natürlich möglichst weit außen
so weit wie so ging neben der leitplanke
wo ist das vom hier und dann bin ich
beim ersten mal
dann will ich eben zur notrufsäule über
die notrufsäule dann hierfür kontaktiert
und dann hieß es okay als dauert 60 bis
90 minuten nicht so geil
es ist ja nur nachts um drei so ich
wollte nur noch nach hause kommen aber
scheiß drauf
so war es dann also und dann habe ich
ihn gewartet auf der abschleppwagen der
kamen dann auch eine stunde später dann
war es viertel voller viertel vor drei
oder so noch später und ja dann hin und
her mit dem abschleppwagen hat meine
versicherung wenig gesagt was mir
endlich hätten sagen sollen
das war schon sehr verwirrend und dann
war ich ja immer noch in münchen bzw
außerhalb von münchen immer noch eine
ganze ganze strecke von meinem
tatsächlichen zuhause entfernt
ziemlich weit sogar also über zwei
stunden
und ja dann musste ich wohl in den
sauren apfel beißen ich hab mir gedacht
okay nach zum 3 ich habe keinen bock
mehr auf die scheiße also echt und dann
habe ich den abstieg hat gesagt ja komm
schläppi karl nach hause da wo ich hier
wohne war es nicht die vernünftigste
entscheidung von mir war denn ich hätte
von meiner versicherung scheinbaren
hotel in münchen bekommen und reparatur
und alles das hat mir aber keiner gesagt
da also die dankeschön an dich lvm
besser laden haben sie mir nicht gut
kommuniziert muss man sagen und hinter
dem moment einfach überfordert weiß
nicht was ich machen sollte ja ich hoffe
ich jetzt habe ich jetzt keine delikaten
informationen die ich eigentlich raus
geben darf aber egal ich wollte euch
jetzt einfach mal wissen
ich wollte euch das noch mal sagen
und ja mal von der situation erzählen
weil in dem moment lernt man ist einfach
so zu schätzen dass man zum beispiel
auch mein handy hat weil wenn eine
solche situation oder handy
aufgeschmissen seid dann seid ihr euch
am arsch und ich habe auch ihr habt da
noch mit dem abstieg mit dem abschlepper
geredet der hat gemeint man geht
mittlerweile davon aus dass jeder ein
handy hat deswegen gibt es diese
notrufsäulen nur noch in relativ großen
abständen beziehungsweise wenn eine
dieser notrufsäulen kaputt geht wird die
nicht mehr repariert sondern einfach
ausgetauscht oder quasi weggeworfen
das ist richtig krass ihr müsst immer
geben was für ein glück ich hatte ich
musste nur 500 meter laufen glaube ich
bis zur nächsten notrufsäule
das war echt richtig l'aquila ja gut
dann komm ich halte ja und dann habe ich
als es wirklich noch ein vermögen
bezahlt für diesen abschlepper und das
hat mich richtig richtig abgefuckt
wohlgemerkt ihr müsst was ich
unterstelle der reifen ist
wahrscheinlich geplatzt weil der andere
typ mir reingefahren ist also der hatte
auf seinem autos und fetten schwarzen
ring of death metal von einem reifen
stammte weil der reifen abgerieben wurde
als er mich reingefahren ist und ja ich
vermute mal dass jetzt einmal alle die
wollen mich sehen wollen weil das grab
schick ist irgendwie auch vielleicht
drei gegen eins wie wär's ja also drei
kann man schon mal machen drei finde ich
schon fährt ja super g so ich möchte mit
meinen letzten sätzen die ein bisschen
aufpassen
ja und wie gesagt also mein reifen alter
hat sich relativ stark in seiner
karosserie abgerieben und hatten kurz
danach den geist aufgegeben so dass wir
die story und ich bin dann habe ich dann
abschleppen lassen von diesem abschnitt
dienstag echtes war so irre teuer ist so
aufgeregt unfassbar also lasse wenn ihr
in so einer situation seit was ich euch
damit geben kann ist wirklich
also achtet darauf dass ihr sicher seid
auf der autobahn der autobahn ist echt
fucking gefährlich also die worte fand
er so schnell dass das merkt man gar
nicht wenn man comics oder down oder you
ab es ist so fucking gefährlich wie
schnell die autos zu fahren passt da
wirklich auf und achtet darauf dass ihr
euch selbst sichert so was alter wie es
fakt nicht sein ernst ja wie gesagt
warndreieck aufstellen warnblinker an
warnweste anziehen für euch ganz wichtig
so ja und noch mehr fand ich soll dann
am nächsten tag habe ich dann zum ersten
mal in meinem leben in reifen gewechselt
was aufgabe bei 30 grad ein reifen
wechselt ist schon knackig weil man da
teilweise relativ viel kraft aufbringen
muss um die radmuttern zu lösen
aber jetzt weiß ich wie es geht nicht
richtig cool wenn es ist einfach eine
coole sache als man dass man so weiß man
beim reifenwechsel muss wenn dann beim
nächsten mal irgendwie eine vollbusige
blondine am straßenrand liegen geblieben
ist weil ihr 4 500 platten hat dann kann
ich sagen hey darling in denen nerven
ich repariere das für dich repariert ist
für dich aber unter einer auflage du
musst mir dann einen blauen okay sagt ja
gut
juli ist ja das war meine story so das
ist bei mir passiert in der nacht vom
fünften auf den sechsten juni
und ich hab mir nach so gedacht liga
erst einmal lieber noch eine nachbar
deiner mutter geblieben hätte die ganze
erde die ganze scheiße nicht passiert
und hält es jetzt keinen stress mit der
versicherung weil das ist jetzt noch
richtig viel
krempel richtig viel arbeit aber gut das
ist halt so passiert generell im leben
sollte man auch nicht nicht sagen ja was
wäre wenn
weil das bringt nichts da fragt man sich
nur selbst ab man sollte sagen okay es
ist jetzt so wie es ist und ich musste
mich jetzt damit muss damit klar kommen
und dann kümmert man sich im öl
entsprechen darum so jetzt gedauert
ok ja das ist was was ich einzige was
ich sagen kann also gesagt trauert nicht
darum dass es so ist wie es ist sondern
sagt mich einfach es ist jetzt so und
ich muss damit klarkommen weil es wird
sich nicht verändern wenn ich nichts
mache ja man ansonsten wie gesagt auf
der autobahn höllisch aufpassen
und wenn ihr selbst autofahrt lasst euch
zeigen reifenwechsels echtes nein das
war es von heute ist meine story leute
ich hoffe es war interessant für mich
war es einfach krass aber ich glaube ist
mal ganz interessant zu hören was sie
privat ab geht das gerne daumen nach
oben da wir sind zunächst wieder haut
rein macht es gut und